yeah a new game playing deformed against
them be damned yeah maybe French I'm
terrible I have no no idea about the
French language unfortunately all right
we've got some on sort of strange dogu
Indian it's very unusual to have this
plate without the nights out hmm yeah
probably hmm yeah for any sort of
refutation I probably need to take it
what what could be the difference there
maybe before i mean i can't play you for
now in the position with 93 and night f6
i cannot go in for obviously maybe this
is the reason why this isn't isn't
played okay if I go Quinn a4 check now
knight c6 d5 mm-hmm why is God he's got
Queen a five but after the exchange
isn't this isn't this probably good for
me yeah that's not really haha yeah I
thought 96 alright so he just gives up
the pawn mmm how to how to continue now
yeah probably i'll i need you i need to
covered the Queen on this have unless
some it's not it's not helping him if he
could play a bishop to 2g for maybe in
number if it was only seven or something
the question is how to continue d5 maybe
I can also take e five just exchange
Queens and play the ending that's both
good come on keep it simple it's early
in the morning okay let's let's play
this this end game this is probably not
the best way to play d5 was probably am
putting on him under under more pressure
but then okay as mentioned i wanted to
to keep it simple the issue is that i
was a somewhat weekly foursquare here
this means it's not so so easy to learn
to convert again from the any to get rid
of this at some at some point so just 92
maybe hmm yeah but the ant is i'm going
to play p5 right it's going to do that
anyway
okay let's let's drop the spec yeah can
you to go here now I have c4 covered on
before I play 95 you can play Knight to
d7 though this might be M of a decent
idea for black my next move will be a 92
no matter almost no matter what is doing
all right yeah this surprises me is
giving me a nice publish TM for the for
the bishop okay let's go here protect
the e4 pawn hmm what is this okay r if I
take a 4 is intending to play 90 for you
but I have Knight b6 isn't this good I
don't believe this if Knight b6 also 97
coming oh no no it's just just down
click night h5 may be intending to to go
f5 this is not not really threatening
much I can just take you five so look
the fort's not working what I can okay
six everything's hanging now is
continuing because them I'm am somewhat
down on time
but down it's not it's not dramatic yet
my my time deficit yeah okay dokey six
was checkmate oh it's not much not much
that we can do anyway 92 I can also play
this one yeah winning the night oh this
is made oh it's not made why not eyes
got this square funny but I have this
young okay fifth now it's made okay yeah
probably d takes d5 wasn't the best but
I wanted wanted the Queen's of curious
is why didn't you play him here this was
was what i was i was expecting the ideas
after d5 to go queen a five actually I
thought that this would the idea a three
would be good but the employee I'm not
sure of it's so clear cut let's say this
a three the ideas if he takes then this
wins the night this is what I calculated
um when he can go here and this isn't
isn't so clear I mean it looks funny but
maybe I'm winning this porn but maybe
I'm not and then it's not clear at all
if this helped me I think this this is
what you what you should have done and
this is basically just just the one
position now its own 95 is stronger or
Bishop e2 okay I wanted to wanted to to
keep it simple yeah thanks for watching